- [Voiceover] Let's take a look at a
United States one dollar bill.
What is it that gives this thing value?
You can give it to people and get back,
ya know food that you can
eat, or things that you
can use, and things of hard value.
But what is it about this
little piece of paper
that makes it valuable?
Or I guess it's not paper, as it's cotton,
something like that, right?
But the questions stands, right, like what
makes this flimsy little
thing, that doesn't
seem to have any use in
it's own right, valuable?
Well, one kind of interesting exercise is
to step back in time a little bit
and take a look at what
the very, very first
United States dollars looked liked.
So I have here one of the
very first that was printed,
and let's zoom in on it and kind of read
some of the words associated with it.
So if we zoom in, let's just
say towards the very top here.
Notice that it says silver certificate,
silver certificate up at the top.
So what does that mean?
Well, if we zoom out
a little bit, it says,
it says that this certifies
that there has been
deposited in the treasury of
the United States of America
and then the sentence kind of continues
in an awkward way below,
one silver dollar payable
to the bearer on demand.
So what that means, what this
dollar originally represented
was the fact that you
were gonna be able to
turn in this bill for a silver dollar.
This piece of paper in
theory, could be turned in
to the United States
treasury, which guaranteed
that it had in its
deposits a silver dollar,
an actual piece of
silver, and I'll show what
one of those looked like in just a moment,
It would return to you for this bill.
So in a sense what gave it
value was this guarantee
that you could turn it
into silver if you wanted.
So this way you could trade
this with other people
as if it were a piece of
silver, 'cause if you gave
it to someone that person, now
being the bearer on demand,
could then in theory, turn this in
and get a silver dollar as a result.
And the reason for even
having this paper money,
and printing these bills
is that it was pretty
inconvenient to always lug
around actual pieces of silver,
and actual pieces of metal.
And this would be
especially true in the case
of even higher amounts.
So for example, here we
have a 10,000 dollar bill.
Something you don't really see too often.
And if we zoom in and
kind of see the guarantees
that are written on this guy,
it's actually very similar,
but its this is instead
in gold instead of silver.
It says that $10,000 in gold
are payable to the bearer
on demand, as authorized by law.
So kind of legally backing up
the idea that this could be
turned in for $10,000 worth of gold.
So that way people could
actually treat this as if it was,
ya know $10,000 worth
of gold, without having
to lug around that much money.
So what is it that you actually
got when you turned in,
ya know for one silver dollar
or something like that.
What is it that was payable on demand?
Well you have, what's
another form of money,
what you can use in
commerce and kind of trade
with people as a medium of exchange.
Officially United States
money, but the difference is
that the piece of money
itself, is the valuable metal.
It actually is the silver,
so in theory if you ya know,
didn't trust the United
States Government anymore,
you could melt it down
for just the pure silver
and maybe other countries
still value that silver.
And similarly there was
gold coins like this
that people would use.
Like this right here is a gold coin
worth two and a half dollars.
So, this is something
where the value is held
within it because presumably
people value gold,
and even if this didn't
have a fancy you know,
United States symbol all stamped onto it,
it would be something
valuable, because it's gold.
And this kind of money,
this ya know gold coins
or these silver coins has
a special kind of name.
It's called commodity money.
Let's see, commodity money.
And basically what this
means is that the thing
that you're using for
money, the thing that you're
trading around, has some
value in it's own right.
Even if it wasn't money, it would still
be something valuable.
This word here, commodity,
basically means just
anything valuable, it
could not only be ya know
silver or gold, but things
like food or furniture
or livestock.
These are commodities.
And you know you could
argue that silver and gold
aren't valuable other
than the fact that people
just like using them for trading.
I mean they're kind of pretty
and useful for jewelry,
and there's some
electronics that use them,
but on the whole, the
main reason that people
value silver and gold is because
they're used for trading.
It's kind of because
other people value them.
So it's a little bit
weird that these are the
quintessential examples
of commodity money,
when in fact other
commodities ya know like wheat
or oranges feel much
more real, hard valuable,
something you can use in its own right,
than the pieces of metal.
But never the less, these
are, these are commodities.
And the other form of
money here, where you have
something that you could in
theory exchange to a bank,
and then the bank would return to you,
ya know the actual silver
that it represents,
the commodity that it represents,
ya know in this case silver.
These are called commodity-backed money.
Commodity-backed.
Because their value is being
backed up by the value of
whatever commodity they represent.
Another term that you
might hear for them is
representative money,
because they are representing
another good, representative.
In this case, silver or gold.
But in the early days of money,
like thousands of years ago,
you would have representative
money like the shekel,
which represented a
certain weight of barley.
So it doesn't just have
to be silver or gold,
sometimes you have money
that represents a different
sort of commodity, so
commodity-backed, representative.
This is the kind of old
style United States,
or other countries money.
A lot of people had
commodity-backed money.
But in modern terms, it's common
not to have either of those.
You can just have this bill
that's not backed up by silver.
You could not turn this in
and get silver as a result.
And this, this is termed fiat money.
Fiat money.
And this word fiat kind of means a decree
or a declaration, so it's
like the United States
Government has declared
that this is money.
And just by declaring that it's money,
presumably that gives its value.
So it kind of feels much
more hollow in comparison
to commodity money, or
commodity backed money.
But there's a couple, a couple
hard things backing this up.
One of them, if we kind of zoom in on
some of the words here.
If you go you see that it says
this note is legal tender.
So here, I'll write that down.
This note is legal tender for
all debts public and private.
And I talked about the
idea of legal tender
in the last video and
how that actually ya know
gives a little bit of clout
to this being valuable
as long as you trust that the government
will enforce it's laws,
as it claims that it will.
But for the most part, what
makes this stuff valuable
is the fact that other
people trust it, right?
The reason that you value
having a dollar bill
is because you know you
can give it to most people
and they are willing to trade
you valuable things for it.
And at the end of the day,
that's what was making,
ya know silver dollars or these $10,000
ya know gold notes valuable.
'Cause almost no one would actually trade
it in for the silver,
'cause why would you?
It's just as good, and it's a little bit
more convenient to just
trade around the bill itself.
So once that's actually in
the psychology of a society,
and once everyone kind
of is used to the idea of
trading around this paper
representative money
in order to get things of
value, it's not actually
a huge leap to just have the
paper that you're trading
around as long as everyone else trusts it.
And it still serves
those functions of money
that I talked about in previous videos.
It's a medium of exchange,
and you can store this
for value, right?
The paper's not going to
degrade, it's something
you can store, and it
does give a unit of value.
Assigning a number to
various goods out there.
But it is, it is just
something that was declared,
it's not an actual hard good,
and this is kind of an
important distinction
to recognize is that fiat
money really does mean
it's just trusted, it's
just taken on faith
that people will find this valuable.
But for that matter, that's also true of
silver and gold, right?
Like, it's just taken on
faith that if you melted
down the silver other people
would find that valuable.
And same goes for gold,
and in fact in some,
ya know even though a
lot of western cultures
valued gold a lot, there
were other cultures
that they might find like in Asia,
that didn't value gold in the same way.
And just thought why is everyone getting
all up in a fuss about this fancy metal?
So this idea of having
money that we use basically
because we trust that others
will find it valuable,
isn't actually that absurd,
and as long as it serves
the same three basic functions of money,
you can have a working society.
Ya know barring things
like hyperinflation,
that makes it so that it no longer serves
those functions of money.
See you next video!